[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi
16 décembre bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 hebdo une émission pour
revenir sur l'actualité dépenses
départementales de la semaine voici lé
titre les impacts et les conséquences du
changement climatique et des
problématiques au coeur d'une conférence
de l'observatoire de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines chercheurs et
spécialistes ont débattu sur ces sujets
jeudi soir révolution sur les campus la
fage double l'unef et devient le premier
représentant syndical au sein des crous
pour commenter ce bouleversement sabrina
cher puis s est repliée élus au crous de
versailles est notre invité est furieuse
dans le reste de l'actualité nous
reviendrons sur le lancement de ski
invest une nouvelle plateforme de
financement participatif dédié aux
entrepreneurs du territoire et les
avancées significatives autour du projet
de l'enfouissement partiel de la
nationale 10 à trappes
mais je vous le disais donc on début de
cet hebdo politique c'est hebdo plus tôt
et de manière avec une conférence
organisée hier soir à l'observatoire de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
autour du changement climatique
chercheurs et spécialistes s'étaient
réunis pour exposer quelques-unes des
conséquences et des solutions due au
réchauffement
les précisions avec mélanie poké et
patrick jacques de dixmude en décembre
2015 195 états s'engagent à limiter le
réchauffement climatique en dessous de
deux degrés un seuil qui entraînerait
des conséquences graves
mais la planète on est déjà touché le
changement climatique il est en route
la vigne est déjà alerté depuis très
longtemps le maïs on le somme de plus en
plus tôt et on a on a gagné un mois deux
dates de semis au cours des trente
dernières années donc dans le monde
agricole
il ya déjà nous agriculteurs se ferment
les yeux mais ça existe déjà
hier soir une conférence sur le sujet
s'est tenu à louvain est ce qu
l'observatoire versailles saint quentin
une première étape pour comprendre avant
tout le changement climatique connaître
les impacts de nos comportements et
comment s'adapter je crois qu'il est
important
justement de ne pas ne pas être
anxiogène c'est à dire que ce qu'il faut
c'est c'est que tout un chacun se mette
en mouvement
mais l'anxiété n'a jamais permis de
mettre en mouvement il faut il faut que
les gens se rendent compte que qui a
certes un problème est que c'est un
problème pour lesquelles on a des
solutions pour lesquelles ces solutions
sont pas nécessairement coûteuse et on
doit essayer aussi de rechercher des
solutions qui sont pas trop coûteuse des
solutions qui amène d'autres bénéfices j
particulier à la collectivité
territoriale tout le monde est concerné
pour que la planète commence à guérir et
le réchauffement climatique la pollution
atmosphérique sont des thèmes au coeur
de l'actualité avec la circulation
alternée mise en place vendredi et
samedi à paris et en proche banlieue
pour tenter d'y répondre d'ailleurs la
voiture électrique semble être devenu
une solution prisée par les villes et
les habitants or dans les yvelines
certaines communes font désormais marche
arrière
la ville de bois d'arcy par exemple a
décidé de suspendre son projet
d'installation de bornes autolib selon
des informations du journal
toutes les nouvelles certaines villes 50
s'inquiéteraient de l'endettement du
syndicat autolib ainsi la ville de
versailles aurait décidé de se côté de
ne plus installer pour le moment de
nouvelles bornes on change complètement
de sujets à présent avec une mini
révolution dans le monde universitaire
depuis fin novembre l'unef n'est plus le
premier syndicat étudiant de france
c'est désormais à la fage la fédération
des associations générales étudiantes
le syndicat a remporté plus de voix lors
des élections des élus étudiants au sein
des crous sabrina acherki bonsoir enfin
vous êtes membre de la fage nouvel élu
au sein du crous de versailles
j'ai évoqué une minirévolution
l'introduction est ce que c'est exagéré
comme terre nous c'est vraiment une mini
révolution dans le monde étudiant
alors oui dans le sens où au niveau
national la fage a gagné
millions de sièges au niveau des
conseils d'administration du crous et
même dans les territoires bastion l'unef
on a réussi à gagner les voix et donc
des sièges alors qu'il ya vraiment un
changement ouais sur 196 élus vous avez
remporté 76 sièges et l'unef 66 pour les
étudiants qui nous écoutent qui nous
regardent qu'est ce que ça change
concrètement la fage à la place de
l'unef
ça change que la fage et à partisane et
que on va surtout insisté sur le côté
associatif le lien entre associations
étudiants est très fort comparativement
au crous et le lien étudiants qui est
pour l'instant le lien est altérée donc
ça veut dire que notre dynamique notre
objectif c'est de renforcer le lien
entre coup ces étudiants parce que
l'objectif c'est d'améliorer la vie des
étudiants alors expliquez nous quel est
votre rôle au sein des au sein des
universités des campus qu'est-ce que
quel est votre pouvoir de décision
d'intervention alors au sens du cros on
peut intervenir sur plusieurs types de
décisions notamment par exemple sur les
restaurants universitaires les cafétaria
parce qu'il ya des preuves notamment lu
vs qu à ce sujet là on peut arrêter
habitations le problème a levé ce qu
juste par curiosité par une certain ut
il ya des restaurants eu qui menace de
fermer ou de changer de mode de
fonctionnement ça pour entraîner des
suppressions de postes de la perte de
qualité des repas donc on voudrait
éviter cela et
et justement ça miaule soutenir
justement cette action alors vous
intervenez dans le monde de la
restauration enfin pour la restauration
aussi les bourses les logements tout à
fait il ya vraiment un problème au
niveau des logements de la répartition
des logements et au niveau des retards
de bourse qu'on voudrait absolument
remédier oui j'ai vu dans votre
profession de foi du syndicat 0 auteur
dans les bourses
c'est réalisable on réalisable en
insistant en étant motivés et en afrique
en en parlant de bourse quand on va sur
votre site internet l'une de vos
propositions c'est aussi l'aide globale
d'indépendance qu'est ce que c'est laid
de global d'indépendance voulait
réformer complètement le système des
bourses et des aides au logement
actuellement la bourse fonctionne par un
système d'échelon donc c'est à dire que
honda près les revenus de l'année
dernière donc sur la déclaration
d'imposition n'est attribuée à un
échelon qui une fourchette de revenus et
donc après on est à attribuer une bourse
mensuellement maintenant ce qu'on veut
faire c'est la lettre l'eau balle dans
des vans c'est pour justement adapté la
demande est là et la bourse vraiment
avoir une bourse plus adaptée par
rapport aux besoins des étudiants
et justement les gens qui ont qui sont
entre deux échoue c'est à dire qu'ils
peuvent retomber d'un échelon pour une
somme aux niveaux annuels de revenus
très très faible du coup ils perdent un
montant de bourse beaucoup plus
important et ça va pas avoir des
répercussions sur leur vie quotidienne
ça permettrait de lisser d'harmoniser le
tout à fait c'est qu'on appelle ça une
généralisation des mousses vos idées par
exemple sur les bosses les étés convient
d'évoquer ce que c'est c'est des idées
qui prennent qui prennent forme au sein
des auprès des décideurs aussi des
autres décidant de l'université auprès
du monde politique oui tout à fait c'est
des projets qui pourraient aboutir à
très long terme exactement il faut
entreprendre les discussions avec les
différents acteurs mais ça pourrait être
très prometteur vous parliez des
restaurants universitaires pour pour
lever est ce qu est ce qu il yad autres
problématiques qui sont spécifiques au
crous de versailles celui où vous siégez
est ce que vous vous êtes attentif à
certains sujets plus que doit alors on
peut comparer le coût de verser à
coulisse de paris qui est un peu plus en
avance par exemple au niveau des
versements de bourse qui sont assez
problématique au niveau des rénovations
des résidents
ce qu'ils doivent être modernisés avec
par exemple les espaces du travail
beaucoup plus adaptée avec du wi fi d un
client pour un vrai équipements et donc
ces installations devront être faite le
plus rapidement possible pour améliorer
la vie des étudiants ce qui n'est pas le
cas à paris et à paris à différentes
problématiques mais à versailles c'est
vraiment ça à versailles on est une
grande académie avec beaucoup
d'étudiants donc ça peut peser en effet
vous nous disiez tout à l'heure la fage
apolitique contrairement à l'unef qui
était très engagé par exemple contre
contre la loi travail on est tout de
même dans une année électorale vous
n'allez pas y échapper ce que vous allez
quand même vous engager dans cette
campagne
et de quelle manière alors le but c'est
de dialoguer avec tous les partis
politiques pour voir leur opinion sur la
vie étudiante et leurs mesures dans leur
programme mais ne pas faire de
ségrégation au niveau des opinions
politiques d'accord et vous serez
attentif aux vous verrez ont finalement
quel candidat ou tel parti est le plus
attentif à vos revendications et
potentiellement vous pouvez le sentir
puisque l'ancien président de la faj par
exemple alexandre le roi lui est engagée
auprès de manuel valls donc de au sein
du parti socialiste
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que la fage
apm une tendance un peu à gauche pas
forcément pas forcément en fait la fin
je suis vraiment tous les objectifs de
tous les de tous les partis politiques
dans le but de savoir qu'est ce qui est
bien pour les étudiants ou non peu
importe le parti
l'objectif c'est est ce que cette mesure
que le candidat présente est bénéfique
pour les étudiants ou au contraire
est-ce que ça peut présenter un vrai
risque de
de perte de qualité de vie étudiante est
ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui que vos
revendications vos besoins avoue son ton
coeur de la du début de campagne
présidentielle ou alors on zappe
complètement les attentes des étudiants
provenant non tout à fait c'est
primordial la vie étudiante
la question de la vie étudiante c'est
tout à fait plus demandez vous vous
estimez que les candidats eux prennent
sans encombre points mi temps oui pour
l'instant oui avec différentes opinions
différentes nuances c'est subjectif mais
tout à fait la question d'un étudiant
que je pense est un point clé de cette
campagne
s'il y avait un chantier à retenir pour
la vie étudiant de demain ce serait
lequel se serait le logement ça serait
les bourses selon vous alors un dossier
sur lequel il faut absolument avancer
rapidement
selon moi c'est une combinaison des
trois parce que bourse logement et
restauration sont liés de toute façon si
souvent les ceux qui habitent en
résidence universitaire bénéficie de la
bourse pouvoir payer leur loyer et
bénéfices la bourse pour justement
manger à midi à leur université
donc tout est lié on peut pas écarter un
sujet voilà et dissocier un sujet de
l'autre merci sabrina cher qui pour
toutes ces précisions et puis du coup
bonne chance pour votre nouveau mandat
et puis pour votre année universitaire
également dans l'actualité locale cette
semaine l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines a lancé officiellement sa
plateforme de financement participatif
sky to invest
cet outil doit permettre aux
entrepreneurs du territoire de trouver
plus facilement de nouveaux financements
reportage d'haussmann ventes de renée
lancement de sky investments 10 14
décembre la plateforme de financement
participatif a pour but d'aider les
entreprises à se développer plus
rapidement pour mettre en place cette
plateforme l'agglomération a collaboré
avec kiosque sous une veste une société
de financement
je crois que le financement est le
maître mot de l'entreprise et que sky
veste
qui se marie avec coeur ce que tout une
veste c'est un une belle perspective
pour les entreprises aujourd'hui que
chacun sait qu'il ya de grands besoins
l'investissement le le sens de
l'entreprise sont des choses qui se qui
se développe de plus en plus et
parallèlement il ya beaucoup
d'épargnants dans notre pays et cette
épargne vous pourrez l'utiliser pour
contribuer au développement d'une
entreprise grâce à la plateforme sky
invest et le choix des entreprises sera
rigoureux le dossier sera présenté au
comité d'audit
on fera ce qu'on appelle des diots
diligence dans le jargon c'est à dire
qu'on va regarder si ce qui est expliqué
vreizh perspectives sont réalistes
non non il faudra quand même
sérieusement présenter patte blanche
avant de pouvoir être financés
contrairement à d'autres site de
financement participatif tels que kiss
kiss bang bang
le scan veste marron cassions qu'à
financer les entreprises favoriser les
l'innovation et les rencontres entre les
différents acteurs du monde économique
c'était l'objectif de la soirée happy in
a organisé mardi 13 décembre à
versailles par le réseau open innove de
la chambre de commerce et de l'industrie
du département pour cette soirée est
dédiée à l'économie circulaire 5 start
up présenté leur projet devant plus
d'une centaine de personnes reportage
vingt candidats et seulement cinq
finalistes les startups francilienne
présente ce mardi 13 décembre au café
théâtre de la royale factory avec
quelques minutes seulement pour
présenter plusieurs années de travail
parmi les concurrents du soir squeeze
une entreprise yvelinoise qui conçoit et
commercialise une gourdes réutilisables
pour la famille ont souhaité quand même
j'irai arriver à une solution beaucoup
plus responsable beaucoup plus
respectueuse de l'environnement et qui
aussi avait un coût beaucoup plus limité
parce que mine de rien le budget gourde
à usage unique est quand même très élevé
lorsqu'on a pas mal d'enfants pour
écouter départager les orateurs
innovants plus d'une centaine de
potentiels investisseurs et décideurs
économiques étaient présents dans la
salle versaillaise il faut que les gens
se rencontrent se révèle et hop on
innove est un véritable révélateur d'un
côté c'est à dire qu'on met en avant met
en lumière des compétences et des
talents sur le territoire dont des start
up innovantes mais ça ça suffit pas il
faut aussi connecter les gens et on se
présente avec open innove commun un
connecteur de compétences prix du jury
de cette soirée dédiée à l'économie
circulaire la boîte à champignons une
entreprise basée dans les yvelines qui
permet grâce à un simple processus
écologiques de produire soi-même ses
champignons
c'est une reconnaissance et un
encouragement à continuer c'est un
encouragement à avancer toujours dans le
même sens et à être fidèle à ce qu'on a
pensé au début on a pas pervertir le
projet a pas le travestir pour le faire
baisser le niveau on doit continuer à
avoir ce niveau d'exigence et a pris
comme celui là bas nous encourage dans
ce sens là également lauréat du prix
public phoenix propose une gestion
éco-responsable des invendus des
entreprises c'est un projet qui va fêter
bientôt ses 20 ans l'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 à trappes semble enfin
devenir réalité l'ensemble des acteurs
du dossier état région département
agglomération et villes ont signé jeudi
l'accord de financement les travaux
pourraient a débuté en 2018 les
précisions avec alors languit notamment
ces images vont elles bientôt appartenir
au passé avec 80 mille véhicules qui
l'empruntent tous les jours la nationale
10 est un enjeux structurants depuis une
vingtaine d'années pour la ville de
trappes ce mercredi 14 décembre les
collectivités ont enfin signé le
protocole d'accord pour l'enfouissement
partiel de lax sur près de 800 mètres
un projet de 95 millions d'euros dont 28
à la charge de la région ile de france
cette saignée urbaine au milieu de
trappes les trappistes ne la méritais
pas j'ai toujours pensé qu'il fallait
réparer cette cicatrice qu'il fallait
futur et ce territoire et permettre à la
ville
rap de redevenir une ville j'allais dire
où il fait bon vivre et où les deux
morceaux de la ville sont recoller les
travaux de l'enfouissement partiel de la
nationale 10 devrait débuter en 2018 la
couverture de l'axé la modification de
deux carrefours permettront de
redessiner en profondeur la commune on
alla de l'espace pour faire du pour
faire du paysage pour faire des choses
qu'ils soient de vrais en entrée de
ville est donc d'accord on rentre dans
trappe on rentre dans une ville qui a eu
qu à une allure qui a un paysage c'est à
mes yeux très important
si le calendrier des travaux est tenue à
l'aménagement total de la nationale 10
sera bouclée en 2021 soit 23 ans après
les premières études consacrées aux
projets en politique cette semaine avait
lieu le dernier conseil communautaire de
l'année
près d'une soixantaine de points étaient
à l'ordre du jour et notamment celui
concernant l'intérêt communautaire cet
intérêt doit permettre de définir
précisément les compétences de
l'agglomération élargi un acte fondateur
pour le nouveau saint quentin or les
élus de la houppe de l'opposition n'ont
pas voté en faveur de la proposition
émise par la droite ils ont évoqué des
inquiétudes concernant la mainmise de
l'agglomération sur certains sujets
comme l'aménagement urbain écoutez à ce
propos bertron lyon le maire ps de magny
les hameaux
il faut qu'on continue discute et qu'on
rapproche les choses maintenant voilà il
a été choisi de faire un vote tout à
l'heure j'ai proposé au président de
reporter la délibération tout simplement
c'est pas un aveu d'échec de reporter
une délibération c'est justement de
sortir par le haut et puis de pouvoir
derrière continuez finalisé on peut très
bien se laisser encore deux trois mois
et à ce propos les 75 élus de
l'agglomération jusqu'en décembre 2017
pour trouver un accord sur cette
question des intérêts communautaires la
politique évidemment c'est aussi les
prochaines élections présidentielle et
législatives à droite l'heure est au
rassemblement derrière le candidat élu
françois fillon c'est le message que
souhaitez faire passer les élus les
républicains de la 11e circonscription
mardi à 13 décembre autour de leur
candidat désigné pour les législatives
jean michel fourgous le maire
d'elancourt ils étaient une cinquantaine
de militants sympathisants prêt à se
lancer dans la bataille
wilfrid richie et patrick est jacques de
dixmude officiellement ce n'était pas
encore un meeting de lancement de
campagne pour jean michel fourgous
pourtant la nécessité d'arpenter la 11e
circonscription pour porter la parole de
leurs candidats aux législatives a été
largement abordé ce mardi soir devant
les militants les républicains présents
battu en 2012 par benoît hamon le maire
d'elancourt entend récupérer son mandat
de député en juin et l'issue du scrutin
n'est pas encore écrite pré requis
indispensables à une victoire l'élection
en med françois fillon à la
présidentielle fillon a été premier
ministre d'une période difficile
1 où la france le monde a traversé une
crise mondiale très grave il a été il a
été bon donc indiscrétions il a
l'expérience
bon il a été élu largement plus
quelquefois la surprise il faut bien le
dire aujourd'hui militants et
sympathisants sont invités à porter le
projet de françois fillon et à mettre
fin aux polémiques naissantes notamment
autour de la santé il faut simplement
osé mettre sur la table sans tabou
on est là pour améliorer les choses pour
que les français aient un système de
protection sociale qu'ils soient
performants qu'ils soient bien sûr qui
concerne tout le monde et en même temps
qu'ils soient financés le lancement
officiel de la campagne des législatives
côté républicain devrait intervenir fin
janvier dans la 11e on espère bien
mettre l'accent sur l'emploi ça dans les
quartiers on sent que c'est une vraie
attente on a beaucoup d'énergie des des
jeunes notamment qui veulent s'investir
qui veulent créer qui veulent innover
qui semble que l'économie est totalement
verrouillé sur les sept communes de la
11e circonscription cinq sont
actuellement dirigées par la droite mais
la gauche peut s'envisager
restée avec la commune de trappes où
siège d'ailleurs un certain benoît le
centre hospitalier jean-martin-charcot
de saint cyr l'école a inauguré cette
semaine un nouveau pôle de psychiatrie
infanto juvénile sur les trois
structures de ce pôle de sont dédiés aux
enfants atteints de troubles de
développement les détails avec camille
lambert 8000 enfants autistes naissent
chaque année en france
ici au centre hospitalier charcot de
saint-cyr-l'ecole la prise en charge de
ces enfants va être améliorée lundi 12
décembre le centre a inauguré son
nouveau pôle de psychiatrie infanto
juvénile qui était important c'est le
coma ce que les québécois appellent le
virage ambulatoire c'est-à-dire au lieu
de subtiliser les maires ou les enfants
24 24 on les prend en charge soit
hospitalisé moncton jour soit en visite
à domicile soit par des consultations
donc c'est une prise en charge plus
légère ça permet aussi de prendre en
charge plus de personnes parmi les trois
nouvelles unités l'hôpital de jour
united' et le jardin d'enfants
thérapeutique
toutes deux sont consacrés aux enfants
souffrant de troubles du développement
une quarantaine seront accueillis la
troisième l'unité parents bébé est dédié
aux difficultés qui suivent
l'accouchement
ça peut être un conflit de couple ça
peut être une mère célibataire ça peut
être une maman qui est porteuse d'une
maladie un enfant qui lui-même est
porteur d'une maladie
donc ça va 2 j'ai envie de dire de la
simple guidances parentale à de vrais
consultations psychologiques
pédopsychiatrique voir voir un
accompagnement médical sur des
pathologies particulières
la dépression post partum toucherait 10
à 20% des femmes elles pourront donc
trouver un soutien si kia trick à la
place de l'ancienne maternologie de
l'établissement au total l'hôpital a
investi 230 mille euros pour les trois
unités
un mot du vendée globe dans l'actualité
avec un coup de projecteur sur le
skipper louis burton originaire de
rambouillet alors que le navigateur est
actuellement dans l'océan indien sa
famille garde le contact en envoyant des
mails et en lui parlant par téléphone à
proximité de la tour eiffel reportage de
miquel et demi d'euros et de patrick
jacques de dixmude
à 31 ans le skipper louis burton vit
actuellement son deuxième vendée globe
laurent boli taille dans l'océan indien
sur son imoca bureau vallée le
navigateur affronte en ce moment le
froid venu dans l'antarctique et les
baleines une bonne
une baleine sur l'humour quoi
aussi proche
il
500 développeurs en bouche pour dire que
comme ça ça doit faire plusieurs tonnes
la baleine et le petit skipper qui sont
bien leurs petits
bien petit un peu plus de 15000
kilomètres de louis burton sa femme la
navigatrice servane escoffier vie la
course entre les studios de télévision à
paris et sa maison à saint malo en
bretagne on la vit surtout intensément
et sans coupure jour et nuit et ensuite
les moindres classement on attend le
moindre e mail pour ça c'est l'ado de
problème si tout va bien et on on sait
que tout va bien une heure après tu peux
avoir une grosse galère donc c'est vrai
qu on se réjouit de chaque 24 heures qui
passent pour communiquer avec louis
burton sa femme là au téléphone une à
deux fois par semaine et lui envoie
environ 5 mails par jour ça va aussi
bien des raconter ce que font nos
enfants que de que des parties
techniques et puis aussi c'est lui dit
verbal de le divertir de le tenir
informé de la vie à terre d actualité
oui burton devrait être de retour dans
un peu moins de deux mois sauf incident
le skipper est actuellement neuvième de
cette 8e édition du vendée globe
noël pour terminer cette émission et
notamment les jouets de noël si vous
n'avez pas encore fait les cadeaux pour
les plus petits aient découvrez tout de
suite les tendances de ce noël 2016 avec
un or l'anguille mais voilà une maman de
plus qui craque pour la youkai watch
tête d'affiche des listes de noël 2016
cette montre n'a pas vraiment vocation à
donner l'heure mais coûte quand même 25
euros heureusement quand il faut faire
plaisir le père noël ne compte pas sans
aucun doute sous le sapin vous allez
avoir
youkai watch donc c'est une montre dans
laquelle vous allez pouvoir england
glisser des petits médaillons et
l'enfant va pouvoir jouer avec
au rayon des tout-petits compter un
budget plus important pour cette boîte
popa trouille les chiens aux allures de
policiers qui devrait faire fureur
auprès des 2 5 ans
59 euros 99 il faut faire plaisir
autre joueur phare cette année les faux
animaux de compagnie profitez-en ses
peluches animées pourrait bien vous
permettre de gagner du temps avant de
devoir acheter un véritable compagnon à
quatre pattes se fait de ne pas de
passer devant il veut bouger pouvons
bouger si vous le secouer un peu il va
se mettre à il va se mettre à réagir et
puis s'il est content à ronronner
enfin si aucune de ces propositions ne
vous inspire rassurez vous les grands
classiques feront toujours la faire
faute père noël venu chercher une robe
de pain ff une petite fille qui va avoir
trois ans et je voudrais le costume de
réponse
on a aussi une grosse tendance cette
année avec les vingt ans l'anniversaire
des pokémon avec les jeux pokémon hugo
et puis les jeux de cartes en sortant
pensé à faire emballer les cadeaux
auprès des associations
un geste gain de temps qui servira aussi
une bonne cause conseils du père noël
c'est la fin de ce set 8 hebdo merci de
nous avoir suivi cette émission est à
retrouver en podcast sur tv fil 78
points comme et puis un merci spécial à
nos stagiaires de 3e salomé car la
maurine lors merci pour leur travail
toute cette semaine bon week-end à tous
et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]